thanks sir okay
all
right so um it is a little after 9 o'
and like to open the subcommittee
meeting on House Bill
um uh the bill to modify the rules for
solo practice
plc's um oh there she
is you weren't 15 minutes late you were
just a few minutes
late so we will we'll pause for a
moment well actually while you're
getting ready I'll I'll just run through
sort of what what my understanding is
and what I've learned um I forgot to
open my email but basically um because
the pllc rules professional limited
liability uh corporations cover a range
of
professions um you know this this the
idea or the need for this bill uh
started with um the veterinary
profession uh solo practice Veterinary
profession and um you know the the base
of the bill was drafted with that sort
of context in mind uh but obviously
whatever we do is going to have impacts
on all of the professions that use the
pllc um corporate structure and so it's
important that we go through the um the
concerns that might arise with the other
plc's I will say that I have um been in
in touch leading up to this with um the
New Hampshire Medical Society um and you
know to see whether or not as sort of
the largest um you know non-legal uh
clinical group that's covered by
pllc um and I'm sorry I'm just trying to
pull up the the final email
um but basically they reviewed the law
they said they had decided initially not
to weigh in on uh House built 82 um they
went back and looked at it again and
checked with their um inter internal um
you know operations and and came back
and basically said that they don't have
any concerns with House Bill 1082 they
also um reached out to oplc the office
of uh professional
lure
certification um I think uh to see
whether they had any concerns um I
hadn't initially because it didn't
really imp impact you know lure it's not
a two-way thing that we're doing it's
it's really just the corporate side of
of plc's and uh oplc came back as well
and said that they don't have any
concerns so neither of those
organizations is taking a position Pro
oron on the bill but they they stated
that they don't have concerns so um I
don't know if anyone else has any
information about other professions or
whether we can sort of move directly to
the questions related to
um uh legal plc's legal profession
plc's um because I I don't I haven't
gotten the sense that this is going to
be a problem for clinical practice
PC's so um with that I I don't know
whether anyone else is coming to the
meeting um Zoe did you ever hear back
from the folks uh I reached out to both
um the New Hampshire BS excuse me sorry
representative
M um I reached out to both the Bor
Association to the Ethics Committee and
I reached out to attorney John
Cunningham who is the New Hampshire Guru
on llll on
llc's um I asked that a witness from the
bar association from the Ethics
Committee specifically come to
testify and I reached out to them about
two weeks ago and they never got back to
me I tried I reached out to them again
yesterday and never heard back from them
so I am to be honest I'm feeling
frustrated about that I do have a copy
of the ethics opinion that was issued
in uh
20120 that directly talks about this
issue um I do have concerns about it in
terms of uh here's the amended
bill so I do have concerns about it in
terms of plc's for uh single member uh
law
practices um so I don't know how to
handle that um and um I did speak to
attorney Cunningham briefly yesterday
and he was strongly opposed to the bill
and I asked him if his if his opinion
was limited to law practices and he said
no I gave him the example of a vet or a
doctor and he said same thing um that a
nonprofessional should not in any way be
um managing a professional Li limited
liability uh company okay so I just one
question on that because I I had seen
some of your back and forth emails with
him um and they seem to imply that he
thought that this would allow allow the
assistant manager to actually do things
that would fall within the realm of
licensure so you know I think there was
an example of you know can it can it
allow you know this person to give
Veterinary medication and then I think
there was another example sorry I don't
have I didn't open that email in front
of me because I thought they'd be here
um so I I I want to disentangle the
question of of whe whether or not
there's some confusion about
what this would authorize someone to do
because I I'm pretty clear I think
correct me if I'm wrong that that
passing this is specifically stating
because it says a non-qualified person a
qualified person is is defined as
someone in the profession that this
wouldn't uh grant them any of the rights
that fall within the lure this would
basically allow them to operate the
corporation corporate side of the
practice um in in terms of either you
know dissolving it converting it to
another structure where they can
actually be the be the um the operator
or um and and again Roger might want to
weigh in you know hire um somebody
outside the practice to to who is
licensed to run the practice until you
know until the a new structure can be
put in place um so that I just wanted to
see if if we understood why the
representative um uh conningham is it um
had those objections it's attorney
Cunningham yeah sorry OB sorry yes I
think the distinction between the
manager or the assistant manager um
being limited to managerial tasks I
think that's clear the problem is
let's use the most clear-cut Example The
Single member
pllc let's use it as an
attorney the single member pllc attorney
drops dead of a heart attack on Monday
morning you have issues of
confidentiality you can't have an
assistant manager looking into client
files you can't have an assistant
manager communicating with clients um I
only brought one copy of the of the
ethics opinion but they rais a lot of
these issues and I think um and you
immediately have an attorney needing to
be responsible
for which cases can be continued what
needs to be done when so the concept
that there is time for an assistant
manager
to um I don't know retain an attorney to
manage the
cases um it just doesn't work and I
think the problem would be the same I
mean I certainly respect the New
Hampshire Medical Society and they know
their business better than I do
obviously but um I would think you would
have the same issues in a in a medical
situation of confidentiality
privacy um need to immediately deal with
patient issues
um I used the example of an accountant
you would have the same issues of
confidentiality um there you have
financial matters
and
um I don't know about the situation of a
vet um you would obviously have the
immediate issues of who's going to do
surgery if that's necessary who's going
to write Scripts
um all of those issues but but I don't
know the specifics
there but I think I think even though
the assistant manager would be limited
to managerial tests I I think it's
problematic yeah you know as as I've
thought about this more I I I think I
disagree uh representative Manos I
because the
specific qualification that the the
assistant managers uh what the assistant
manager can do is subject to 304 D5
which specifically says
that the uh you know somebody that's not
a professional can't do any of the
professional things and so I guess you
know in your exam I mean I don't get me
wrong I would agree with you that if a
solo practice attorney
dies uh and has you know an assistant
manager in the practice that assistant
manager what that assistant manager can
do is going to be very is going to be
pretty limited compared to what the
attorney was doing but for example I
would think the assistant manager can do
things like pay the other staff pay the
rent on the office uh you know pay the
taxes that that were that were due or
those kind of things and I would think
and you know the client
files I I think that's I I'm not sure
that it that it is so black and white in
other words if the if the assistant
manager under the direction of the
attorney were while the attorney was
alive was was able to um you know if if
for example if the attorney if the
attorney while he was alive he or she
was alive said to the assistant
manager can you look in client X's file
and uh uh find out who who his treating
physician was and send the treating
physician a letter I think the the the
assistant manager could do that even
though the assistant manager is not an
attorney once the assistant manager once
the attorney has died it's not clear to
me that automatically the assistant
manager can no longer look in the file
um you know I maybe that's true but
maybe not but I guess
to
me it it seems like the way this is
worded what likely would have to happen
very quickly in the case of a of a
lawyer probably a doctor or anyone else
is that the the assistant manager would
have to be in touch for example with the
bar association and say you know I know
that for example I know that the bar I
know you Bar Association have procedures
for how fi client files need to be
handled Etc when when an attorney dies
I'm calling to let you know that
attorney Smith has died uh you know I'm
the assistant manager in his practice
I'm gonna pay the rent and pay the
employees and do those kind of things
but um I really need an attorney to be
here because there's some things that
have to be done that may have to be done
pretty quickly I need an attorney to be
able to look at over the files and do
those kind of things and I would think
that that that you know that that would
be a similar thing would be done with
medical practices or dental practices or
whatever so that that I think that's
that's my view on this I I think that
this that this would be all
right um did you have any thoughts or
insights into this represent me yeah I
guess I guess my thoughts are
a are more grounded in the the idea that
there are lots of
business entity options and I I and I I
hear both representative Manos and
representative Lyn's points I I think
they're both they're both valid
um and I I do I just wonder if starting
over was there a better
option for the scenario that that that
that led you to filing this legislation
and I I I don't know what what that
answer would be and
I um I think the fact that for my
understanding estate planning kind of
played a role in why this issue kind of
bubbled up I I'm concerned
about kind of
intertwining
two related but somewhat distinct areas
of law
um and I'm not sure I have the answer to
that um
I I do understand the human aspect of
starting off thinking that you have the
right idea that the pllc is is the right
idea for your professional practice for
one's professional practice and then
realizing that you have um estate
planning concerns and that business
decision doesn't necessarily fit in that
in that box
and I yes yeah that that that is kind of
my concern just the fact that there that
we there are other business options and
they are it would be difficult to
convert from one to another possibly I'm
not exactly sure but it does seem like
these
are there are two competing interests
that are that are kind of trying to fit
into
one business entity right now okay if
that makes sense I mean you can yeah no
I I think that I think that is a good
statement of of the Crux here I I I I
think I I'm starting from the
perspective and I may I may invite Roger
if you're interested to come and and
respond to that as well um because there
are plc's that are Solo practices um you
know good number across the profession
so the the issue exists to the extent
that there are single practice plc's my
understanding is um other than the legal
profession which
um uh representative Manos has has
uncovered guidance on what should happen
um or at least what could happen um the
other professions do not have this
guidance and they sort of require this
kind of Unwritten
unstructured relationship to be
established um that basically says if if
this situation arises you know this
other person who has no relationship to
your your practice or or your business
is going to basically agree to step in
and function in that way this would
allow the assistant manager for example
to change the corporate structure to say
uh we're no longer a pllc we're just an
LLC and and then basically go forward in
that way Roger did you want to waigh in
on sorry Mr gown would you want to weigh
in on this Roger is fine um right so
let's remember let's go back to the the
whole point of this is that absence an
assistant manager you have somebody
who has to step into your practice who
has may have no relation to it that was
the the corporate structure that we had
in our practice for many years and the
successful practice to ours now that
it's sold also has that structure
because that's how a PLC has to oper a
single soul member PLC has to operate um
it's not ideal to say the least and the
goal is to is to solve that problem um
any any structure any revision of the
law that solves that problem you know is
going to be better than what we have now
um I think it's important to to note
that absent an assistant manager there
is nobody to appoint a
new a new legal structure a new a new
operator to the for the business the
business is going to fall apart um the
business has to go to probate or an
executive has to go to probate court to
get permission to do the next thing and
in that time the business is going to
fall apart so that situation is much
worse than than any reasonable thing
that could happen to to
wind down the business in a sensible way
um I definitely recognize the the
professional concerns the assistant
manager should not be operating in any
kind of professional capacity but in a
medical office there are not there are
people who are not doctors who have
access to medical records and they're
subject to Hipp rules and all those
kinds of things um in a legal office
there are par professionals and I assume
that they also have have um ethical
standards that they have to follow
so just because someone is not a
licensed member of the profession
doesn't mean that they don't have ways
of operating properly within the
profession um the assistant manager
might be the office manager of a of a
dental office or something like that who
knows perfectly well how to keep the
business running for a short time
they're not going to do teeth tooth
extractions or whatever the thing is but
they can go find somebody they can get
the patients moved to other practices
they can get the business converted to
an LLC all the things that have to
happen you know the other thing I as I'm
sort of thinking about this and I um I I
have I I I don't know all of the
implications of the ethics opinion but I
mean it would seem to me that in as I
recall what what happened when you know
when an
attorney died or became uh incompetent
or whatever um the Supreme Court um
would appoint an attorney to kind of you
know wind up the person's practice but I
I don't I mean I never really got into
the details of this but I would be
surprised if the attorney that did that
was being told you know would would
would understand that he or she was
taking on the
responsibility of like what are you
going to you know let's just say the the
attorney owned U the practice owned a
building what are you going to do with
this building you're going to get rid of
the building you're going to sell it
you're not going to sell it I I my
impression was that the attorney would
the attorney's job that in that in that
role was to sort of take over the client
files and protect the client that that's
that's the role that the attorney would
have and that there would still
be you know a a fairly significant area
of sort of nonprofessional stuff that
that um the attorney would not be taking
over that's you know that the attorney
was say wait a minute I'm not you know I
don't know what you that's not my that's
not my job I want to I'll I'll make sure
that the clients get notified that
they're interests are protected that the
statute of limitations doesn't run on
some claims or whatever but you know
whether you're whether you're paying
your employees or whether you paid the
rent or whatever that's not that's not
my job that I I would think that that
would be
um I I really wish we had somebody here
from the ethics opinion from the Ethics
Committee of the bar association but um
I only have one copy of of the ethics
opinion um and maybe we can get copies
but it does it does say
that as you mentioned replin the supreme
court appoints somebody an attorney but
then they do have the because the law
practice is an asset of the attorney EST
State um and so um so part of the job is
to now I don't know how far it extends
but um let's see I was just reading here
um uh I'm sorry I lost I lost where I
was
um oh it says required task if
appropriate work with the personal rep
representative of the of the deceased or
incapacitated attorney to facilitate a
sale of the practice under New Hampshire
rule of professional conduct
1.17
so um although that appointed attorney
may not be getting into the weeds of um
selling the practice or dealing with the
with the practice as a financial asset
um they would work with the personal
representative of the deceased attorney
or incapacitated attorney to do those
nuts and bolts or make sure that those
tasks get done um required task um
required task wind up the practices
remaining business Affairs and close the
practice so it does it does touch on
some of the nuts and bolts that we're
talking about
um right but you know I guess what I I
mean it I mean even if that's even if
even if that the the attorney could do
that I I wonder if isn't part of the
whole idea of having the having the PLC
is that
it as opposed to a you know just a solo
practice of individual proprietorship
that having the
pllc one of the ideas of that is to
facilitate being able to transfer the
business I mean I I always thought that
that was one of the purposes of having a
pllc was being a able to say well the
business does not end just because you
know whereas it would with the with the
with the death of a solo practitioner
who was an individual practitioner the
pllc would not would it would go on and
so you know again I I'm I'm still sort
of back to I I don't really see how I I
I I understand there will be overlap and
I certainly think that one of the things
as I think you pointed out
representative tur at the beginning of
this one of the things that
would obviously have to happen very
quickly in these one of these situations
is to get
the is for the assistant manager to be
in touch with the bar association or the
medical society or somebody that is that
is qualified so that they can make you
know they can make the those decisions
that do have to be made professionally
but I I I'm still not I still don't
think that this is problematic the way
it's word so I um so I'm wondering
listening to what you just read
representative Manos if these two things
can be harmonized because that um ethics
opinion and I don't know if we can cite
that I don't know does that does an
Ethics opinion have any sort of legal um
standing or or is there a way to cite it
because I guess what I'm say thinking is
maybe a Way Forward is to say something
along the lines of to the extent that it
does not conflict with you know
something like the ethics opinion
because I mean I I was glad to hear be
reminded that the ethics opinion does
sort of talk about working with the
representative it seems like it would be
easier to work with that representative
if that person was able to
function in the role of a corporate um
manager or Corp corporate operator as
opposed to just you know the inheritor
of you know essentially a defunct legal
practice or a defunct Veterinary
practice right you know this way the the
the whoever the court appoints for the
legal opinion would have an entity that
was able to actually do the things I
think that that person would ask them to
do which is sell the building or sell
the practice or convert the practice or
do you know but not actually have that
person have to do those things and I I
do recognize that you have to go I do
I'm I apologize and I so I guess but I
you know if you maybe you could put
something like you know uh something
like saying in you know subject
to um uh some language like subject to
uh guidelines or or ethic ethics
uh uh decisions issued by the the
profession in in question or something
like that um that I mean that I think
that's I I guess all I'm saying really
is I don't think that I think that the
the idea here is a good idea and that we
shouldn't you know we we shouldn't like
just say it can't be done that's that's
kind of where I'm coming from and
exactly how it gets done you know maybe
we have to work on a little bit but and
I'm sorry I will you're intent is to
come to come back okay I'll keep this
I'll make sure we keep this
open is go quickly if you are done I
mean don't wait around just for me I can
I can no okay I think we can keep this
open as long as you all don't have
anywhere else to go there's certainly
you know there's there's certainly
plenty to
discuss um so I I guess in in in in
light of what Bob said does does that
help in any way um representative Manos
in terms of making it clear that
whatever Powers this I me because
there's there's two things I think that
we could do in Amendment one of them is
affirmatively state that the assistant
manager cannot exercise any professional
judgment and maybe that would clear up
the question which sounds like it's kind
of lurking which is you know where's the
line you know and for me for any medical
lure or any lure I should say I always
consider it to be the exercise of
professional judgment is TE technically
what you're being licensed to to do um
and I certainly would think that we
could get around that by clarifying
maybe just clarifying that you know
because the the practice won't be able
to go forward the way it was going
forward before obviously I mean this is
this would be some sort of a
catastrophic event that would lead to
this
situation um clearly these things happen
currently it sounds like in the legal
profession there is some guidance it
sounds like in the clinical professions
there isn't guidance and a must admit I
did not reach out to the the
um you know accounting um or or
profession um but I guess what I'm
thinking is if we can find a way to
include some language to a clarify that
whoever the assistant
manager is they cannot exercise any
professional judgment because they're
not licensed um so it's sort of implied
but not stated currently and then the
second thing would be to put some sort
of language in there that makes it clear
that the guidelines of an ethic you know
and again how I would cite this in the
law maybe this is a question for uh um
uh um OS to to figure out how to State
this but you know to say that you know
this should not put us in conflict with
you know the professions and any
guidance they have about this
this um Roger did you want to say
something you just talking about
guidance I just wanted to point out that
right now the guidance is coming from
PLC attorneys or you know somebody that
you an attorney that you hire to
organize your business and and what
they're telling their clients as just as
a regular course of businesses now you
have to go find this other professional
who's going to be willing to step in
because otherwise you're you're you're
really going to have even worse problem
right right I I think that makes sense
and and I guess I'm also trying to think
like you know a profession is a couple
of different things it's obviously you
know it's a it's a very small group of
people with with very specific training
and knowledge you know it's
also sometimes competitive um it's also
sometimes um you know if you're in Solo
practice you know could be isolating
could be you know that you've just moved
to the Lo the area you know I mean I'm
also trying to expand like obviously the
situation that you're talking about
you've been in practice for a long time
you have a lot of connections um I'm
trying to think if someone comes to the
state and they're not connected with
anyone you know this could be a really
awkward thing to ask someone to do and
and again it doesn't carry for me it
doesn't carry the the the weight of you
know a legal a legal framework it just
sort of says on the side try and work
this out with
somebody um yeah
um M maybe representative M you can you
can kind of remind me in that ethics
opinion is there anything that discusses
the difference between llc's and plc's
and what benefits are conferred by plc's
because my my main concern is that the
there's there's an obvious difference PE
the LLC structure is available to
professionals
so I was just hoping we could have like
some kind of conversation about what
what benefits are conferred and why um
why
PES um this opinion does not talk about
that
distinction
um it does not talk about that
distinction but it does talk about on
the point that that remind me of your
name uh rais um it does say
um however in the meantime even if an
attorney has done such planning and
specifically meaning Estate Planning and
specifically authorized another attorney
in a succession plan to administer his
or her practice in the event of death
disability impairment or
incapacity and this is the important
point that that Authority ter terminates
upon the attorney's death following
death only the estate's personal
representative I.E the attorney's
executive or administrator has a legal
authority to administer the estate's
assets which would necessarily include
the attorney's
practice so I think that that's really
the nub of what you're what you're
running into because I agree I can't
offer legal advice and and I'm not but I
agree that I think an attorney who's
handling the formation of a pllc would
advise exactly what you just said to
arrange with another successor
professional to take over in the event
of the death or incapacity of the of the
primary uh
professional
um but I see the point here that on
death everything it's the Estates
administrator that becomes the
responsible person um you end up in a
catch 22 essentially yes yes
and in this at least in this ethical
guidance I'm not seeing any way around
I'm not
seeing you end up in a catch 22 exactly
and so that's why at least in the legal
context you immediately have to get an
attorney appointed by as replin was
saying the New Hampshire Supreme Court
to immediately step in on the
professional side
um Rog
the the legal profession appears to have
taken care of its needs in this area um
the other professions have to go to
probate probate court and spend months
and in that time the the practice
dissolves so this is kind of where you
get into this problem and I I would say
just listening to that and correct me if
it's not a good interpretation
but it sort of conflates the corporate
asset with the
estate um
in a way
that maybe isn't required in other words
like here it's sort of assuming that the
practice as a corporation is essentially
dead um that it that it that it no
longer exists or or or and Roger shaking
his head so I may be completely off Bas
but um that that was my thought was
essentially this would allow the
corporation to continue as an operating
entity as part of your estate as opposed
to a dead entity as part of your state
right right that's the goal I mean for
the the the the so proprietor wants the
value of the practice to whatever extent
possible to be able to be extracted and
given to the estate right and if there's
no way to operate it at all the value
that value is going to go to zero very
quickly right right and so this you know
it's less the way things happen these
days maybe than it used to be but like a
medical practice you know could be sold
you know you have have a group of
patients you have a building you have a
staff you have you know a set of records
and things like that you know if the
entity can't operate obviously the
medical practice dissolves and falls
apart and has no value um as opposed to
saying you know as a corporate entity it
can go forward and it can take steps to
resurrect the situation in a way where
the value of the practice and its role
can can be preserved to a greater degree
than could have happened if you know
it's just basically dissolved um and I
think that's the goal of this and Roger
correct correct me if I'm wrong so you
know to me that is a kind of an
overriding concern and again it's it's
trying to really separate ah good
good I hope we're making some Headway
we're trying to sort of talk through the
idea of better better separating sort of
the professional you know what what ha
if someone dies which I think is the
cleanest example but they can also be
you know disbarred or or whatnot you
know what diet is a cleaner example
because it sort of takes off the
whatever could have caused you to be
disbar um you know in other words if if
this if that if the practice becomes
part of now someone's estate you know
must the practice
essentially lose all of its value
because it can't it can't find any way
to go forward as a functioning practice
or or in this instance could you could
someone step in as an assistant manager
and take the
corporate make the corporate choices not
the not the professional choices to to
allow that entity to continue and and
essentially recover from the
situation represent me yeah uh thank you
so I think the so the concern I have is
that um so limited Li liability
companies are Partnerships at their core
they're people focus and I think a c
Partnerships a different isn't isn't a
partnership different than a is a
partnership different from an LLC I
don't know I mean in the RSA it's it's
it is listed under the partnership okay
um sorry no that's that's fine and there
is such a business entity as a
professional
Corporation and
not like not so many words the the whole
point of it is that it exists
after the shareholders potentially die
um this is a professional a professional
Corporation professional Corporation
yeah so the corporation
exists it you own shares just like any
publicly traded company except it's a
private
Corporation
um
so again not not to be so unfeeling to
to your plate but there
are um Legal Professional options and I
and I can see how maybe not to speak ill
of your attorney but um maybe someone
who is more focused on business
practices wouldn't
necessarily um consider all of the
implications related to Estate Planning
and I just wonder
by doing this are
we are we undermining the whole point of
a
pllc well I'm not an attorney but um
what I gather is that the PLC structure
is what attorneys favor for um all these
situations and I can't sit here and tell
you why okay thank you I I did do a
little looking into what a pllc is and
the the biggest thing and I know I've T
mentioned that to you um represent Manos
that it seems as though the biggest
reason has to do with the ability to
separate um professional liability you
know which again might mean that it's an
interesting choice if you're a solo
practitioner there is no separation of
for professional liability but um as as
Roger just mentioned Mr G just mentioned
um you know it does seem to be the the
practice form of choice
for many most most profession most
professional practices I don't know the
proportions um I know I I hear pllc used
a lot in in professional
circumstances um so I think to the
extent that they exist or that that that
we're not saying you can't be a solo
practice pllc then it sort of falls back
to us to say how this might best be
handled because I mean the other option
would be to say that you just can't
can't be a solo it doesn't make sense or
there you know or or or it's just in
conflict with you know corporate logic
or corporate law to say that you can be
a a sing solo practice pllc because
essentially it puts us in the
catch22 um but again I don't know how to
weigh the the the value of of of a of a
professional Corporation versus a pllc
other than that you know I use the
economist's way of valuing things if
somebody wants it then it has
[Laughter]
value yeah um I have a I have a
suggestion I don't know what our timing
is and replin can can give us that but
I'm wondering uh attorney Cunningham
made it very clear that he just doesn't
have the time to come he's got the
willingness but not the time to come I'm
wondering whether we have enough time to
reconvene and hear from somebody body an
attorney who is uh um educated and
conversant in the in the distinctions
between an LLC a pllc and other forms of
organ business
organization who can talk to us about
these issues and maybe I can try again
to get somebody from the Ethics
Committee maybe I'm worried about
something that you know maybe I've got
something stuck in my craw that I don't
need to have stuck in my craw um
and I'm willing
to uh to be disabused of that of that
notion um so I'm wondering about that as
a
possibility before you jump in
representative Lynn I I guess I I just
want to sort of go back to the thought
that I just had a minute ago which is to
the extent that this can exist legally
this situation can exist legally I I'm
trying to avoid us getting into the
realm of was this a good choice of your
corporate structure you know um can I
just yes I I I I was I I realized that
that's probably on me like whether it
was a good like a good choice or not oh
no not not so much that sorry I was I I
was trying to say I I I'm trying to just
avoid that discussion overall I I I I
would as well and um yeah like CH
choices do have to be made and I would
just generally say that they usually
have to when it comes to business
entities it comes down to a few things
it's ownership it's um investment its
taxes um and just generally the expense
I think a professional Corporation is
probably more expensive than a PLC which
is why a typical attorney might suggest
that um and it's just one of those
things that it it's very dependent on on
the client so one that's very concerned
about those issues and it's it's hard
like with a state plan it's hard to
think 30 years down the road is this
corporate structure going to be
important to me when I'm ready to retire
and I'm starting to think about what
what's going to happen what's going to
happen to my employees um what's going
to happen to the value of the business
when it when like if if I die what's my
spouse going to do with it if there's a
catastrophic incident and we both die
where where does that go those are not
things that people naturally think about
when they are just starting up their
practice and once you start it's really
hard to think
about changing Midstream yeah sorry so I
was going to say is I mean we we don't
have to EXA this tomorrow but I think we
do have to ex we either do have to
execute or interim study it I think by
next week because the crossover you know
we have to be we have to be done by
crossover and we could we could refer it
for term
study um
I I I guess I'm you know the more I've
thought about this so I
it
I I I really The more I've thought about
it I I really think that the way with
the amendment the way it's worded is
okay and I because I I tend to think I
mean a non- lawyer can't practice law in
fact there's a actually just a crime I
mean it's a crime for for so I
don't I guess I
don't
see and particularly given the wording
of the uh of of the bill I don't see
that
there's a danger of of it suggesting
that lawyers that a non- lawyer could
practice law I think that the you know
that that as I said before before there
would if if a solo practice pllc lawyer
dies there's not there's going to be a
lot of things that the assistant manager
can't do
but um I think there's I think there
probably are a number of things that the
assistant manager can do that don't
involve the practice of law that um I
don't see why we shouldn't allow the you
know the law shouldn't sort of
specifically state that that can be done
both for lawyers and other professionals
yeah can I can I throw out a suggestion
maybe that's splits the baby if that's a
reasonable analogy how about if we and I
don't know whether you think this would
help uh represent Manos um or me um if
we were to draft an amendment that
embodied either or both of the two
things that I mentioned one is basically
adding you know clarifying that it that
it does not allow professional judgment
or and another one clarifying that
you know and and I I I defer to U
representative Lynn or others for the
language but to say to the extent that
it is not in conflict with you
know any any law governing the pra the
professional practice or or any guidance
governing the professional practice
something along those lines so that so
at least we're basically acknowledging
that we have this ethics opinion
that after If This Were to go forward so
that would have to be Harmon ized in
some way sort of like maybe is what's
happening right now the the guidance
that someone's legal team could
give couldn't you say something like you
know um have a last sentence or
something that would
say um you know this this amendment does
not allow a professional does not allow
an assistant manager to perform uh any
duties that um are of of a professional
nature or that would or that would
raise
um or that or that would uh uh I don't
know how you'd phrase that would violate
um um ethical standards of the of the
practice of the ethical standards of the
of the uh profession that is in question
something like that I me and ALS and
also acknowledge that in the legal
profession there's a process that has to
be followed and and this doesn't get you
around that this doesn't say I'm just
going to go forward as a pllc without
going before the court and getting a new
attorney appointed if that's what the
the PC manager decides because it
doesn't sound like you actually
necessarily I don't know whether you you
necessarily need to appoint someone else
to do the legal windown of the practice
it sounds like maybe you do based on
ethical guidance yeah I that's what I
want to make sure that what we say here
does not say in any way that that
doesn't still have to happen um because
it it does this sort of just says you
know if we can keep the lights on and
pay the bills maybe this can wind down
in a in a more you know graceful way
than you know ENT because that sort of
implies that language and that opinion
imply implies that um that that the
practice sort of is is a dead a dead
legal practice when when maybe it could
you know find A Better Way Forward if
somebody's willing able to be brought in
so yeah go ahead representative M thank
you um I think I could live with the
line of of thought that we're going down
I just would want to point out uh to
Roger that it doesn't solve his problem
because you still then have the need to
have a vet who's going to
presumably um to do the prescriptions
and do whatever surgeries are pending
and all of that stuff so you you you
would still need to make the arrangement
with another
professional to step into the shoes and
handle all of that but but but it does
give the assistant excuse me for
interrupting it does give the assistant
manager the legal authority to hire a
relief veterinarian for example to keep
the practice
going um or to begin negotiations for um
bringing in uh an employee veterinarian
who might then be negotiating for the
purchase of the practice you know there
there there are a bunch of different
structures like that what we have today
is there's there's no authority to do
anything and I would say if if if I can
if we can work out this language quickly
perhaps you could run it by attorney
Cunningham and see whether or not that
eases his concerns um because it it's
tough when someone sort of takes a
strong position but is not here in the
room for the you know and and i' i' I'd
be reluctant to sort of reschedule this
for another hearing when we're not
really sure that folks would be able to
attend so um yeah represent no you know
I was the the I think you you raised a
really I think important point is that
and even in the ethics opinion as I
understand it seems to if the if the
solo practice that's not a pllc if the
lawyer dies they the the
the opinion the ethics opinion seems to
reflect
that the that that one of the things
that a new lawyer would would one of the
things that the new lawyer would sort of
undertake is
um working with the representative of
the you know the personal representative
maybe the wife or husband or whatever of
the of the deceased lawyer in terms of
selling the practice and so that that
seems to suggest that even though the
lawyer
has died and even though it's a solo
practice the that practice still has I
mean it does continue to exist in some
sense it has a value it can be sold and
so doing it you know your point about if
it's in a if it's in a pllc it makes it
much easier to sell it uh because that
the corporation lives on so to speak I
think that's uh that you know that's a a
very valuable reason for having a
pllc
so I I'm good with what you suggest also
okay does that sound okay representative
Menace yeah yes it does it's it does
sound fine to me um I guess the question
becomes how we're going
to draft the amendment to the amendment
um circulate it get all of us to kind of
sign off on it and then and then I'll
forward it to attorney Cunningham and
the Ethics Committee and get them to
weigh in yeah so so represent Lynn as
our chair chairman sure yeah
um is it your understanding that this
has to somehow be acted on this week or
would we be able to push it back no we
can we don't have to execute this week
but we do have to execute next week in
other words we have to execute by the
13th I think it's yeah 13th and so you
know if you want I mean there's no
reason on the
13th I think we'll probably get through
most of the bills that we have you know
tomorrow so we won't have a lot of bills
to deal with on the 13th but if we have
this one and maybe one or two others um
if you want to have you know if Mr
Cunningham or somebody else is available
to come that day they can you know they
can talk hopefully we'll have given them
the language and all that stuff ahead of
time we'll have we'll be ready to go but
if if uh he wants to come and you know
give us his input that would be great he
can do that for sure yeah but I think we
should have the you know we should have
the amendment like ready to go by then
yeah that's what I was going to say at
least by then we could have worked out
some language had it drafted perhaps and
then basically if attorney Cunningham or
others still have concerns then at least
we're talking about sort of something
that's already acknowledged most of what
they've provided so far so it'll get us
down you know I don't I don't want to
open up our our exec session into a a
you know a hearing right right right
exactly does that does that sound a
reasonable way I will I'll I'll work on
on the amendment with with everybody but
I I'm I'm still I still kind of hold
those same concerns I had before and I I
would would like to hear from from the I
I would like to hear in person about the
the the ethics opinion um I just does
everyone have did you circulate that to
everyone email right yeah by email I
thought I had it um because I already
looked you know what I and I didn't
print it you I know
I can certainly would you mind sending
yeah would you mind because I know I I I
know you I remember the email saying
that you know it was attached I'm just
not sure that I I will send it I I was
able to open okay that'd be great and
you know representative CH I I I I
understand that this probably feels like
like it's like it's a little hard-headed
but no
um and that's you know maybe this is
part of the reason why attorneys have
reputation that some have
right but it it it is
um these these exists for a reason and
without hearing from someone who
practices business entity law in New
Hampshire I I'm uncomfortable with
adding what what appears to be
reasonable I will say it it it is
certainly reasonable um and I and I I do
I do feel for your
situation
um it just touches on too many aspects
of the law for me um to to sign off
completely without hearing from an
expert okay I I I will say this was
drafted by Rogers business attorney who
who put this forward um I didn't you
know come up with it uh he's just one um
you know obviously L the bar association
or anyone else would be would be so are
you okay with the path forward that we
will draft an amendment that tries to
embody what we've talked about and see
if we can get that before people who
might have a more critical eye yeah yes
absolutely okay yeah I I I think we
should we should definitely try to do
what sounds right and what what seems to
be right
and I would still like but yes yeah okay
great so it's it's 10:00 let me yeah go
ahead represent could you could we just
restate as a group what our goals are
for the amendment to the amendment um we
want to have subject to subject to the
ethical constraints
of are subject to the ethical
guidance
um yeah I don't even know if it needs to
be limited to ethical it can be any
guidance by the Prof any guidance that
you know or or or I don't know what the
right word is rules set forth by the
profession I don't know Bob if you if
sure subject
to
um maybe this
um this author this nothing nothing
contained here in shall uh
authorize um an assistant manag how like
nothing nothing contained here in shall
authorize an assistant
manager to
perform
any
U any professional
duties um
or any duties of a professional nature
or that would uh
conflict that would conflict in any way
with with uh
ethical uh standards for the for the
profession in question or something like
that or or maybe or maybe yeah I guess
what I was thinking was the two pieces
are one and I'll State these in plain
language um one is not allow not allow
the assistant manager to perform any
professional duties or judgment and then
the second one is shall not be you know
in conflict or in any way you know maybe
obviate is the right word you know the
practice from following you know the the
the guidance that the profession has set
out for for this circumstance or
something like that sure sure yeah so
it's so it's those two things that says
we're not we're not endr running the the
the bar association and we're not and
we're not end running the
lure
um yeah maybe just one more quick
question I feel like you may have
addressed this is the goal for the
business to just continue or is it
mainly to get
from
um get to a point where you don't have
to essentially send the business through
probate to sell
it th those things are intertwined yeah
so if the business has to go through
probate the business is probably not
going to be able to continue um if and
it's going to be an individual
circumstance whether the goal is to
continue
or to wind it up in an expedition
fashion the business may have no value
um but if the business has value then
the goal is to extract as much of that
value as possible and also for the sake
of the clients to have continuity which
is which is also an extremely important
goal so there's a bunch of things that's
wrapped up there I just to clarify I
suppose I I meant long-term um that
would the business continue obviously
the business needs to continue in order
to wind it up um
as opposed to just dissolving on its own
um yeah so the goal may be to continue
the business as a as a functioning
professional entity into the future and
there's a bunch of different ways that
could happen Okay thank
you representative M um I'm wondering if
I
can
um write up the goals that we we just
talked about and or you could rep T and
send them to OS tell them our goals for
what we want to accomplish and then have
them draft the appropriate language to
add to the amendment yeah I I don't know
whether it makes more sense for you to
draft rather than draft the goals I
think I'd rather see us draft an
amendment so we are actually talking
about the language that we would think
and then basically I'm not sure how we
do this without you know being having a
91a problem but circulate or or or
receive individual input from each
person on our subcommittee to um you
know to make sure we're all on the same
page are are you in here
no good answer
um so does that make does that yeah you
know what I I I I I do tend to think it
would be better for us to give them the
language and maybe they tweak it a
little bit but if we if we just sort of
send them the ideas I I you know I'm
there's a lot it'll take it'll take
longer I think to get what to what we
really want so all right so so do do you
want to start or do you want me to start
I'll start okay okay so just mark up the
amendment then I guess and will embody
because we did we adopt this amendment I
can't even remember I don't I don't
think we ever I think we did I don't
think we did I don't think we so so we
will just have to have an amendment that
incorporates the new language from the
amendment plus whatever we we from
today's discussion all right and so for
tomorrow I mean the one thing for
tomorrow we will just we'll just sort of
give the give a report to the full
committee on where we stand but we won't
we won't we're not going to exec the
bill tomorrow perfect okay okay great
well thanks everyone for the time this
is uh as I said never use the word
simple when you start talking about a
change to the law so all right well
thank you than all right thank
you